hello and welcome to Week in Review with
me Jane secor Kevin McGuire and Andrew
pierce a here to look back at the
biggest stories of the last seven days
what have been your top stories own goal
by the BMA in calling the longest of a
strike in the NHS okay Kevin I think
it's got be the European tackling 11
billion bite out of Apple overtax points
well more on both of those stories in a
second but first let's get a taste of
what the week was all about it was
announced the gene wilder the star of
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
and blazing saddles had died at the age
of 83 his family said he passed away due
to complications from Alzheimer's
disease tributes were also paid to Tom
Jackson the Briton who is severely
wounded trying to stop a fellow British
backpacker being murdered in Australia
after he died from his injuries after
nearly four years British Airways
resumed flights to Iran following the
lifting of sanctions against Tehran
singer Chris Brown was arrested on
suspicion of assault with a deadly
weapon police had surrounded his home
waiting to detain him he SAT inside
protesting his innocence on social media
football's transfer window closed but
not before more than a billion pounds
have been spent by the country's top
clubs and thousands of people gathered
in Boone all in Spain for the annual
tomatina food fight an estimated a
hundred and fifty thousand kilos of the
red fruit were held around the town in
an hour long food fight
always really fancy doing that actually
looking arranging a kid arrange it and
one of the things that we mentioned
therein week in a minute was the death
of gene Wilder desperately sad and
somebody who for so many people we walk
from the chocolate factory was really a
big part of their job well I loved it
and I think having watched the Johnny
Depp version no comparison and I also
saw it on stage in London a couple of
times of my god children it was at one
of the greats as was he one of the great
comedy greats and I'm terribly terribly
sad the last year's his life was
blighted with the orphan I'll son yeah I
think Jim Carrey got it right when he
said if there is a heaven and he'll have
a golden ticket because he was such a
brilliant comic actor and it was that
way he could look really charming and
sinister at the same time him he played
mad very well didn't it was great yeah
so from sad loss this week well this
week after a few months of relative
peace the wall battle between the
government and junior doctors regime the
British Medical Association announced a
series of five day walkouts beginning
later this month but now some senior
doctors are beginning to shy away from
supporting their colleagues skies chief
political correspondent John Craig
reports the medical profession is at war
with the junior doctors being accused by
their senior colleagues of putting
patients at risk in a hard-hitting
attack the Academy of Medical Royal
Colleges is calling on the junior
doctors to call off their strikes we
know there are genuine concerns about
the contract and working arrangements
but we do not consider the proposed
strikes a proportionate says the Academy
five days of strike action particularly
at such short notice will cause real
problems for patients the service and
the profession this decision wasn't
taken lightly at all doctors don't want
to go on strike we generally hate going
on strike but it's just extremely
unfortunate that the government has left
junior doctors with absolutely no other
option hospitals are already starting to
make contingency plans for the strikes
but NHS bosses also say patients will
suffer it's very difficult to trace
particular deaths to
strike action what we can say is that
there will be a significant impact on
patient care when you have this level of
disruption then it's much more difficult
for the NHS to provide the right quality
of care and clearly it increases
potentially increases the risk the
junior doctors are lining up for a fight
with the government which could last
many more months how significant you
think it is that some senior doctors are
slightly raining back their support for
the g one is slightly raining back in
the massive you raining back and the BMA
are flatly refusing to say the voting
split on the ruling council which voted
for this strike action yes this has not
been put to the doctors they rejected
the contract admittedly in a referendum
in the summer but they've not been asked
to go on strike and this is relying on
the strike vote from last year five days
is and it is an historic all-time high I
think they're in this now we'll lose the
junior doctors the huge public support I
think they deservedly enjoyed and it's a
massive own goal by the BMA they should
tell us the vet voting breakdown because
the suggestion was it was dead heated
the first time and it may be one or two
this time and if the senior doctors
disowning it I suspect quite a lot of
the junior doctors well to do you think
em that the BMA is doing a very good job
of representing the junior doctors they
went to the government they got what
they thought was a deal the junior
doctors thought a deal had been reached
everybody seemed happy and then now it
turns out that the BMA doesn't well why
well junior doctors didn't think a deal
had been reached that a deal was
negotiated but the junior doctors
rejected it so they didn't accept it and
you've never showed any public support
for the doctors throughout so you spare
us the crocodile because it bear all
about me barrister crocodiles as a piece
of their operations cancelled the
Academy the senior doctors also call for
Jeremy Hunt to reopen talks if he wasn't
imposing the new contract this wouldn't
be happening if he wasn't health
secretary this wouldn't be happening if
Theresa mayor had appointed somebody
else this might have been avoided it's
not happening in Wales Scotland Northern
Ireland it's only happening in England
where Jeremy Hunt has picked a fight so
when you look for blame and I think
cancelled operations always regrettable
absolutely but if you want blame go to
jail
go to the dr as he is right no no also
let the BMA put this to a vote of the
doctors do they really want to go on a
five-day strike in one month and they
say they're going to do this every month
right up until Christmas and if they're
so confident they've got public support
tell us the breakdown of the beer mail I
heard of represented the beer make
council 6012 we can't tell you the intro
they won't confirm 6812 permit they're
badly split the syria doctors have
disowned it the junior doctors are about
to surrender the one weapon they had
public support and their ill served by
his lot the militant trade you get get
to the unity ama get to the nub of the
matter doctors work in day out dear day
in day out saving lives their dedicated
they'd ought to go on strike they will
lose money your your health Secretary
Jeremy Hunt is pushing him against the
wall by imposing the contract can I tell
you why the contract this would not
really just very briefly one of the
league doctors leader said this is the
trade union dispute at the century and
there you have it it's all about party
politics his lot at a party politics
transitory right window to zap lame
party pride let's move on we could go on
for half an hour and this but let's move
on to our gaffe of the week and this has
to go to the author of one of the more
cringe-worthy articles on the internet
this was entitled how to talk to a woman
who was wearing headphones and it went
more than viral it's also
self-proclaimed dating guru dan bake and
offered a five-point plan for attracting
the attention of a lady his attention is
elsewhere includes such valuable nuggets
as having a relaxed easygoing smart so
I've got a propos I'm gonna put on these
headphones and you can give me a winning
smile and see if I can take them off oh
dear to the words I have also advises
that if a lady is ignoring them would be
Romeo man should point to their
headphones and say take off your
headphones for a minute I thought that
and pretend to be taking the headphones
off your head so she fully understands
all waving waving at the lady it's
promote ridicule on Twitter with lots of
people advising him if he was ever
approached by approaching a woman to
just keep walking yeah to see you good
to see covered the same advice if men
are wearing headphones on women
to attract their attention presumably
not sexist idiot no well I think I think
he's trying to advise man who haven't
got a lot about them and they'll have
even less if they do this I saw one
response urgell well the bloke won't be
able to talk to me anyway because
through the fog of pepper spray yeah all
right some great ones Martha Mills says
we we wear the headphones we fill our
ear holes to stop you getting in the
best advice for getting a woman to take
off their headphones don't leave her
alone was my other one Ben Coleman
suggested you could record an audio book
that's an excellent way to get but a PP
bum on Twitter odd name I said I think
Dan bacon is confusing women with black
cabs yeah that's very clever yeah yeah
right don't forget to send us your
nominations lots you nominated that this
week using the hashtag W in our now this
week ipod became i owe you when apple
was ordered to pay 11 billion pounds and
backs taxes to the irish government
skies James Matthews explains it was in
the 1980s an apple dropped anchor in
Ireland more than 30 years later a
win-win business relationship has
suffered a big loss to tax rulings
granted by Ireland have artificially
reduced apples tax burden for over two
decades in breach of EU state aid rules
Apple's base in cork is the hub of an
operation that's created profits for the
company and jobs for the country more
than 6,000 so what was apples Irish deal
the company records at sales in Europe
the Middle East India and Africa through
companies based at Cork in Ireland
however because of an arrangement with
the Irish government it moved most of
its global profits through a head office
which was nominally based in Dublin but
actually existed on paper only with no
employees or premises and so wasn't
subject to Ireland's 12.5 percent
corporation tax it meant that Apple
effectively pages one percent tax on its
European profits in 2003 falling to an
astonishingly low 0.005 percent in 2014
which when you do the math on it works
out at 50 pounds for every million
pounds they were looking which is which
is pretty low text that's Ryan in
Britain or work or us to pay twenty
percent standard rate and their getaway
nor point normal five percent I'm glad
the european union's got tough were
these tax avoiders apples usually
profitable great thorns and other
devices but we should pay tax in the
countries where you make the profits
instead of having all these cons and I
hope they now go after courses
allegations against Google which
diseased evil Facebook eBay and Amazon
miss donnel's starbucks got caught look
got them they might sell what we want to
buy but you've got to pay your tax do
you think the European Commission should
have this power though if they're if
they are subverting EU state aid rules I
think that's right i don't think they
should you know actively air to tell
countries what they can what tax they
can and can't levy because that's
federalism gone mad but I think if
they've gone for Ireland over this they
should also be going for luxembourg
where junko the president of the
Commission created an incredibly
generous tax structure which is where
companies like starbucks or damas
architecture okay that that is the next
that's the last port of course she
should have done them here and go after
Holland and also the City of London the
channel islands cayman islands british
virgin islands all those big network of
havens operated out of London British
territories they we have to pay our
taxes these big corporations should have
to pay the tax and very wealthy
individuals because at the moment
they're paying a lower rate than anybody
else right quick quiz for you now I
before the break out can you tell me why
lady in Florida was left reeling by some
barefaced cheek
no they don't know if you know that have
find out after the break acta we can
review with me Jane second i'm joined by
kevin maguire associate editor of The
Daily Mirror and Andrew Pierce
consultant editor of The Daily Mail
before the break we asked if either v
knew why lady in Florida was left
reeling from some bare faced chic you
didn't get it had no idea not a clue
let's have a look ah there there it is
tulisa sander was sat on a patio playing
on a phone when she looked up oh and
there was a bear in front of a white
Mike skin she filmed the encounter on a
phone as they sniffed around her and she
texted her son to say help me and he
thought she was joking he she texted him
a photo of the bear with help me he was
in the house and he thought it was a new
app that she has and then she takes him
again saying don't make a lot of noise
and he realized that he came out and him
coming out of the building scared the
bear away Wow but AG on tastic isn't it
remarkably calm and of course if you
move suddenly then you might say I
thought well we're at the bear come from
there were note the woods oh yeah what
do they do in the wood I hope maybe shot
it it was also a memory week this week
for six people who finally returned to
Earth after spending the last year at
living on Mars confused skies Rebecca
Williams explains emerging after a year
in isolation in this dome six people
among them a pilot an architect and a
journalist they've all been simulating
what it would be like to live on Mars
night and day they've lived in this dome
on a mountain in Hawaii without fresh
air or fresh food the lava covered
landscape was considered the closest
earth-based environment to conditions on
the red planet the group could only
venture outside in space weeks
whilst in isolation the group were able
to exercise their provisions included
powdered cheese and canned tuna which
made fruit and pizza all the more sweet
on the outside celebrating with friends
and family now they're earth-based
mission is complete experts believe a
real trip to the red planet could take
between one and three years and now the
race is on for NASA China or Europe to
get there first and it's interesting it
was food that was the big thing they
missed or when when i spoke to tim peake
when he was at his face and he was ain't
was the greenery was the thing he missed
and and also fried oyster hiding one
shower a month and one of the people who
came out said I never felt dirty or
greasy nobody complained for me smelling
that's cuz the other stank to high quite
clearly i do I Brent in the Kraken in
the Himalayas once and because no one
has a shower you don't realize but they
were a bit disappointed it was overcast
when they when they came out stead of
being sunny why not the easy shun yeah
what you really learn you probably you
probably learned more from tim peake
being in the space station for six
months because he liked a lot of gravity
they didn't and you would know all the
time you'd probably just like a ring and
you could get out if there was a real
emergency while if you stuck up in it in
space or Mars because 36 foot wide
they'd have to get on pretty well
wouldn't they I know yeah not my cup of
tea at all no right let's take you onto
your choices of top paper stories of the
weekend Andrew were starting with you
and this is jeremy corbyn and JK Rowling
and well they haven't fallen out but
what happened was she's fallen out of
his support and she she said that Jeremy
Corbyn is not Dumbledore Dumbledore of
course is the great wizard in a Harry
Potter series i'm a huge Harry Potter
fan I've not always been a fan of Jay
carrying but a big supporter the Labour
Party she said that she's not a great
fan of Corbin and she suffered the most
appalling trolling on the internet but
you stood up to them and fought back and
why is she not allowed to say that
Jeremy Corbyn is no wizard cuz he
clearly isn't watch it good speaking of
mind very early on to the others and
here you can know you left never left no
need out of her opinion no that's right
jeremy corbyn's never claimed to be done
Bob
in theaters to him but no she gets a lot
of terrible abuse got it to Juneau
Scottish referendum to and she was
against Scotland brick and a breaking
away but I really like it because she's
never forgotten where she's come from
hugely successful people love reading
the books must be worth hundreds of
millions of pounds now she gives it lots
charity still gives particularly
single-parent families so some of the
some of the abuse inured havin any idea
what life's like is absolute nonsense
she used to go hungry to feed a kid
indeed indeed that was one of responsive
this week wasn't yeah yeah so that's a
one route other one in Brazil Kevin a
bad week for the brazilian president
dilma rousseff absolutely should been
kicked out of office by a Senate that is
tainted by corruption and scandal itself
and it's a tragedy really because in the
nineteen seventy she was imprisoned by
the military dictatorship in Brazil and
tortured and there she's been kicked out
by a bunch of right-wingers who have
installed in a right-winger as the the
present cheese on the left she's not
accused of lying in her own pockets it
is that state banks were used to boost
the economy in a way that wasn't it
wasn't admitted and I think that's not
what you want your present to be doing
is making the road so but you don't you
don't want a scandal-hit Senate then
toppling somebody he was voted in by 54
million people if you want if you want
to get rid of the president have another
election she'd see what Brazilians want
don't don't [ __ ] your ass he's really
paying the price of the fact she's taken
the economy like so many left is
crashing on the rocks because they've
grew very fast in Brazil but the fell
even faster and it's down to her and a
mad reckless nomad spin spin policies
good riddance I say absolute nonsense
you clearly clueless about politics okay
move on Andrew what about politics here
brings it home work for trees majors and
all the cabinet did you see that
fabulous picture in the cabinet in check
it is a fabulous I actually thought I'm
sure we might be able to bring it to you
even yeah well she it was odd attending
we've ever seen the cabinet with them
talking in cabinet in checkers before
she's next to the cabinet sector sir
jeremy heywood is wearing a very
unpleasant tires that his club do you
think Evan but she has made quite clear
Briggs it means Briggs it and there will
not be a vote in parliament to trigger
article 50
which is the mechanism which begins the
process of withdrawing litany you and we
don't need that though we had it was
called the referendum and seventeen
point six million was voted to leave and
she's going to start embracing him quite
good for she has no idea what rexes she
does now it felt like well she said show
me your exit but but what does it mean
in terms of policy means there's a red
line and free movement of people is no
longer you know afflict this country her
are and the seventeen point six million
people who voted today will say good
that's what we wanted we do not want
free movement of people here free
movement of labour possibly but not
people coming here scrounging and
sponging and / running our communities
you see that free movement lay but
that's what he thinks it now means going
to be in the single market gonna keep
the you know picking around a single man
yet you're gonna need to think about it
it's part of the EU you can spout your
slogan brexit is brexit you clearly
loans that you clearly not read the
electoral reform society report saying
people felt very disappointed by the
remand referendum debate amber Rudd
she's been across in France this week
hasn't she talking to her counterpart
there been at kazanov what's going to
happen with the arrangement that a2k
arrangement which is the we have a
border over there so so people don't get
into Britain if they're there either
migrants or refugees seeking seeking
seeking asylum what really is going to
happen is if the socialist government of
Francois Hollande stairs in power don't
start today then the baggage that are
then the border will remain where it is
both the main right-wing challenges are
actually saying they want to move it so
if you forget your Tories in power in
France the border might move and that's
big implications because it would make
would make it harder to deal with people
who are trying to get in the brim I
don't think it'll happen apt I think
it's saber rattling by the right to try
and win the election in France and don't
forget the main right-wing Challenger is
Sarkozy it was interior minister in
France in 2003 signed in the 2k
agreement with David Blunkett in Britain
no greenhorn any of those paper stories
unusually thanks for taking us through
though what about your ups and downs and
reverse started with you this week and
you're sending up Rosie Ruby sighs
sweetheart care of Bobby Dazzler aren't
they gorgeous and they were born conjure
mine twin so of course the chances of
survival were seniors incredibly limited
and look at them now that I don't have a
25-percent chances they doing and off to
school this week great tribute to the
NHS that they are still here with us and
off to school next week and they are
little crackers are in southeast London
and good luck to the other family yeah
you got to meet them this week yeah I
bumped into them and I are no they okay
look like that yeah there are no they
are they corrected they cry they're
absolutely de like racism making music
for no man take him away but I look not
denying it is he but I love it you're
right i'm raising the doctors who have
about 10 minutes ago you were just like
it off no just like not being a kevin's
big difference so we're sending them up
well done to them in lovely story but
you're sending down this week badgers
the cull has been extended this is going
to upset Brian May and others because he
owns four badges but they found more of
the bovine form of well the Bigfoot for
badges and the color is going to be
extended I'm not an expert on this but
there are a lot of questions about
whether it's effective whether it's
whether it actually does stop the
transfer know the code and it's a huge
issue and they do look very cute but of
course they are also very distinct
people who are expert signers do
question the call and whether this is
the right way to control and bovine TB
TB cost the taxpayer and 2015 100
million pounds in compensation to
farmers because they had to get exactly
it is so distract the answer is yeah but
it met it but it may not be killing
badges needlessly okay so ascending at
the extended cull down Kevin you are
sending up this week brown shoes yeah
under the earth but didn't know you had
that pace corneria yes but no it's a
Never Never brown in town as the old
slogan but it's the social mobility
Commission has said that people are
losing out jobs in banks if you turn up
in brown shoes because bright
working-class kids don't know the dress
code of these are possibly now also the
universe ya know she feels so these
issues Oh could you wear shops that
would be a good thing to add to be up
but you know but the economy works out
it's the only on still so he loses out
it's not only unfair and bright
working-class kids can get these jobs
because self-perpetuating elite
come out and do things like clothes we
bankers have only been greatly
successful for the British economy that
is like a lot this report also said
don't wear white shirts do interviews
get very boring keping always wears
white so it's kind of tell you this used
to be a white shirt but he put this
shirt in there on wash as you thought
right we're sending a brown shoes art
but you're doings out through to heaven
this week baby names million Molly and
Mandy they're sitting on Everest very
very sweetly always one in one in five
parents you know boys or girls what
doesn't matter what's their gender
fluidity pit then yes there was it just
wasn't recognized one in 105 parents
read regret the names they give give
their children particularly the parents
who call their kids I guess after the
after the y after the Egyptian goddess
now of course Isis is in a racket yeah
Elsa mum sue called the children else
early for frozen came out and now every
other rather than this board Elsa moms
you called their kids Kevin really
regret it too because they've had a my
turn I did I did appeal this week of
anybody had names that they've been
given a regretted chap called a Randy
wrote in my life has been made misery
yeah he probably isn't everybody's
brought joy to all of us we're gonna
half I'm so a setting down unfortunate
baby names thank you very much to keep
your nominations that coming in for us
using the hashtag W in our if you've got
anything you want to send up or down
well thank you very much for joining us
for a review of the week we'll be back
with much more next week but for now
it's goodbye from them goodbye and it's
goodbye for me goodbye